[Music]
in ursa kayla green sixth earth sea
novel the other wind there is an
incredibly important set of what seem to
be rather
simple questions that are
asked and they're not really answered
until the end of the work they have
incredibly
important implications for
all of earthsea and all of the
we might say rational creatures of earth
sea the dragons on one side in the west
the kargs in the far east and the
archipelago heartich-speaking people who
use magic
in the
middle and these two questions are
coming from the former arc mage ged who
lives on gantt who is there in chapter
one and alder comes bearing them when he
comes to the court of the king lebanon
and meets tehanu
for the very first time
we have this this interesting depiction
uh she put her hand to alder in the
manner of the people of aya and then
lattes as the others had done but it was
her left hand she held out he touched
his hand to hers palm to palm hers was
hot fever hot she looked at him again an
amazing glance from the one eye bright
frowning fierce then she looked down
again and stood back as if she wished
not to be one of them wished not to be
here
master alder bears a message for you
from your father the hawk of gaunt the
king said seeing the messenger stand
wordless tejano did not lift her head
the glossy black hair almost ri hid the
ruin of her face
my lady alder said dry mouth and husky
voiced he bade me ask you two questions
he paused only because he had to wet his
lips and get his breath in a moment of
panic that he'd forgotten what he was to
say but the pause became awaiting
silence
tahanu said in a voice hoarser than his
ask them
he said to ask first
who are those who go to the dry land
and as i took my leave of him he said
ask my daughter also
will a dragon cross the wall of stones
so alder is coming
giving this message which is not really
a message instead it's a
riddle or an enigma or rather
set of riddles right who are those that
go to the dry land
then later not in the same batch but as
an afterthought will a dragon cross the
wall of stones now if you've read your
earth sea novels you know that the dry
land is the land of the dead that humans
go to or at least
archipelagons go to perhaps the kargs
don't they they believe that they're
reincarnated but everybody else goes to
this dry land which ged and aaron
know quite well although they they're
not you know happy thinking about it
the wall of stones
is the border that separates the the dry
land
from or you know part of the dry land at
least the part that the dead have to
stay in
from the land of the living and who can
actually cross the wall of stones
we know that mages can but that it's
pretty dangerous business and you can
wind up trapped on the other side as
happened with thorian the summoner when
he came back
not all of him came back as we know from
previous stories
so these are some really central
questions they
help to provide a
reference point a focal point and they
go on in this this passage the dry land
the king said and the dragons his alert
gaze went from face to face come he said
let us sit and talk
perhaps we could talk down in the garden
so the little gray-eyed woman tenar the
king agreed at once
alder said heard tenors say to him as
they went she finds it hard to be
indoors all day she wants the sky
and they're finding out about alder's
story and they're not going on
necessarily to those questions
a little bit later
what we're going to find is
tahanu
is
going to say
to the king i'm sorry i have to be alone
sir i will think about what my father
said i will try to answer what he asked
but i have to be alone
please
lebron and bowed to her and glanced at
tenor who went at once to her daughter
and put an arm around her and they went
away in the sunny pool the sunny path by
the pools and fountains and you know
what do we know about tahanu well we
have this really great
passage where
tenar is is actually talking with
alder and she says
oh if i knew what she is i'd tell you
her voice full of grief and love and
bitterness she's not my daughter born as
you might have guessed or known
she came to me a little child saved from
the fire but only barely and not wholly
saved when sparrowhawk came back to me
she became his daughter too and she kept
both him and me from a cruel death by
summoning a dragon coalescing called
eldest and that dragon called her
daughter
so she's the child of many and none
spared no pain yet spared from the fire
who she is in truth i may never know but
i wish you were here now
safe with me
and
tahanu is trying to sort this out on her
own
tenar would like to be able to help her
with it but she can't actually help her
solve these riddles
later on however we find that maybe
others can make progress tenar speaks
with the princess
and they talk about dragons there in the
kargish lands and the dragons there are
different than the dragons of the west
they're
little things that don't speak and don't
appear to be rational but they're a sign
of something important of the
possibility of rebirth and they talk
about that and this is in
the
council meeting
and
she says in her at her there are dragons
small wingless they don't speak but
they're sacred
she reminded me that my people don't go
where your people do when they die the
dry land that alder speak tells of it's
not where we go the princess and i and
the dragons
lebanon's face changed from weary
reserve to intense attention
gets questions to hanu he said in a low
voice are these the answers so maybe
that's the way to solve this riddle and
tahanu says
i know only what the princess told me or
reminded me i'll speak with tahanu
about these things tonight
so they're still trying to sort it out
they still don't have answers to these
questions a little bit later yet
there's another discussion of this but
this involves more people tahanu is
discussing the matters with lebanon
alder onyx and tenor are there as well
and it begins here
tahanu the king said he'd sat down
beside tenor in the deep window seat i
didn't call on you in council today to
speak of the questions lord sparrowhawk
asked you it was not the time
is it the place alder watched her
she considered before answering she
glanced once at her mother who made no
altering sign
i'd rather speak to you here she said in
her hoarse voice and maybe to the
princess of her at her
after a brief pause the king said
pleasantly shall i send for her
and tahanu says no no i can go see her
afterward i haven't much to say really
so she's been thinking about this entire
time but she doesn't have that much to
say
my father asked who goes to the dry land
when they die
and my mother and i talked about it and
we thought
people go there
but do the beasts do birds fly there are
there trees does the grass grow alder
you've seen it
taken by surprise you could say there's
there's grass on the other side of the
wall but it seems dead beyond that i
don't know
tahana looked at the king
you walked across that land my lord
i saw no beast or bird or growing thing
alder spoke again lord sparrowhawk said
dust rock
tahanu then says i think no beings go
there at death but human beings but not
all of them
again she looked at her mother and did
not look away
tenor spoke the karkish people are like
the animals
they die to be reborn
onyx says that's superstition forgive me
later lady tenor but you yourself tenor
says i no longer believe that i am or
was as they told me arha forever reborn
a single soul reincarnated endlessly and
so immortal i do believe that when i die
i will like any mortal being rejoin the
greater being of the world like the
grass the trees the animals men are only
animals that speak sir as you said this
morning and then the wizard says
but we can speak the language of the
making by learning the words by which
segoy made the world the very speech of
life we teach our souls to conquer death
that place where nothing is but dust and
shadows is that your conquest her voice
was not dry now and her eyes flashed
so to answer this question who are those
who go to the dry land
human beings
human beings who have in some sense
conquered death
but only by
making death itself immortal and
forcing people to live there
as shadows as mere names without
the connections that they had lovers
pass each other on the streets as we
know right nothing changes in this dry
land
they go on the king intervened lord
sparrowhawk asked a second question can
a dragon cross the wall of stones he
looked at tahanu
it's answered in the first answer she
said if dragons are only animals that
speak and animals don't go there
has a mage ever seen a dragon there or
you my lord
onyx pondered only for a moment before
he said no the king looked amazed how is
it i never thought of that no we didn't
we saw none i think there are no dragons
there
my lord alder said louder than he had
said in in the palace there is a dragon
here and that is where the discussions
end
these questions are going to run
throughout and the answers
really do
bear upon
the connection between human beings and
dragons and what it is
that the wizards
did
millennia back within earthsea so these
two questions
don't get fully answered
or they get answered but in a kind of
trivial sense the real answer is going
to come towards the end of the novel
you